les ministres du gouvernement trudeau
multiplie les visites en alberta un
signe d' écoute alors que les tensions
sont encore vives dans les prairies à
ces gens d'affaires le ministre des
finances par de la place de l'industrie
de l'énergie dans la transition vers une
économie faible en carbone
mais il ya un sujet épineux que bill
morneau préfère éviter pour le moment la
mine frontières nous n'avons pas encore
où la poutine était de considérer la
situation
donc j'ai rien de dire en ce moment le
méga projet d'exploitation des sables
bitumineux divise le gouvernement
trudeau
le cabinet doit décider d'ici trois
semaines s'il donne le feu vert à cette
énorme mine dans le nord de l'alberta
la pression monte et vient même de
l'inter ni des membres du caucus libéral
n'hésite pas à exprimer publiquement
leur désaccord face au projet notre
marque de commerce repose sur la cible
d'être neutre en carbone d'ici 2050 si
nous sommes sérieux frontières ne peut
pas aller de l'avant quoi ce député
libéral de l'atlantique
il n'est pas le seul à exprimer son
opposition nous avons fait des promesses
à nos enfants sur les changements
climatiques
ils devront agir affirme ce libéral
ontarien est fondamental qu'on atteigne
nos objectifs nos cibles de paris est
nocive pour 2050 l'environnement est un
enjeu très important par rapport au
projet spécifique je vais laisser le
cabinet se prononcer en temps réel
comment réconcilier les promesses
environnementales et les intérêts
économiques de l'ouest le débat fait
rage au caucus et au cabinet aussi des
bâtons et prendrons une décision dans
les prochaines semaines confirme cette
ministre de la colombie-britannique
confortable le ministre steven
guilbeault anciens militants écologistes
préfèrent éviter de prendre position
il y est souvent les enjeux avec
laquelle nous nous avons les grands
débats et discussions c'est quelque
chose qui est je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est très important mais au
final le ministre de l'environnement
prévient que ses collègues devront se
montrer unis peu importe la décision
dans une cabine et nous devons prendre
les décisions ensemble comme une équipe
c'est plutôt rare que des députés
s'exprime avec une telle ouverture sur
un sujet aussi controversé
une preuve de la complexité de la
décision qui attend justin trudeau et
son cabinet d'ici la fin février un
rappelle aussi qu'il devra l'expliqué
avec doigté aux canadiens et aux élus de
son propre cas ici louis blouin radio
canada ottawa